hey leute und willkommen zur sieg video
von dem aller aller geilsten zieht den
ich je gefunden habe bisher dem ie zu
gesendet wurde beziehungsweise den ich
je an sich gesehen habe das ist für mich
einfach der beste zieht und deswegen
steht auf dem titel den es einfach nur
gibt's so was habe ich noch nie gesehen
in minecraft und wir sollten dem titel
und zwar sind es drei dungeons in einem
das ist der sieht der 64 15 43 23 85 09
31 3 4 871 creighton wir uns einfach die
neue welt das ist zwar alles ein
bisschen abgelegen sag ich mal so erst
mal hallo und herzlich willkommen zur 90
ich bin komplett und ich zeige euch das
jetzt mal ganz kurz und zwar ist bei mir
ein 1.4 amazon back dass ich immer am
anfang hier aus der welt falle hallo
aber das kann bei euch auch anders sein
also ich musste einmal klein moment
warten und zwar sind die koordinaten iks
- 359 y ist 14 also y ist die höhe und z
820 das ist vom spot es mal ein bisschen
fliegen aber ich habe mir gedacht dass
ich das ganze ist ich bin hier immer
noch zusammen rum backen
ich habe mir gedacht dass ich das ganze
nicht überspringen werde das fliegen
weil sonst bestimmt einige meinen ja
wenn nicht das überspringen also dann im
gelände dazwischen mache oder so dass
dann zum beispiel kurt schwarz wird dann
bin ich wieder da das dann bestimmt
einige sagen werden ja du kannst ja auch
da nie etwas anderes rein fliegen
naja jedenfalls kann es auch sein dass
er am anfang diesen fehler bekommt dass
ihr nämlich hier einfach sport irgendwo
in der höhle oder so das war wenn ihr
vorhin der fehler weil dadurch einfach
eine hürde gesprochen also ich mal ganz
kurz nach draußen ganz kurz hoch also
ihr könnt auch selber austesten das
geklappt so ich bin im moment draußen da
bin ich also hier sind als auch hier
sind fett ab hier sehe die koordinaten
wir müssen x3 159% muss auch also z muss
820 sein das heißt wir fliegen jetzt
einfach in diese richtung
die ganze zeit und auf diesem weg
begegnet ist ein paar schöne sachen und
zwar zum beispiel haben wir hier 3
berg und wisst ihr was ich mache die
zeit bis wir da sind einfach ich spüre
es einfach vor dass es eine gute idee
das heißt ich lege ein bisschen musik
macht die bisschen lauter dann sind wir
sofort da
so und da sind wir nun auch schon wieder
zurück und zwar sind hier wartet man ich
zeige euch ganz kurz hier sind
koordinaten moment hier 359 820 als team
müssen wir gleich runter gehen
allerdings haben wir hier auch schon
eine mega fete schlucht und daran ist
dass quasi angeboten das heißt sie haben
wir erstmal ne fette schlucht und
allgemein ein ganz cooles terror und die
wir müssen hier einfach runter das heißt
die koordinaten ihr seht schon - 359 820
wenn man es jetzt hier einfach runter
graben bis y höhe irgendwas also gleich
losgeht schon darauf neue jetzt jetzt
moment jeden moment da schaut euch das
an warte ich lieber kürzer fackel
zieht euch das mal bitte einfach rein ja
wir dann schon mal eins hier ist dann
schon nummer zwei und hier ist dann die
nummer drei das kann einfach nicht wahr
sein was ist das für ein geiler sie
bitte dass ein dungeon auftritt ist
extrem selten das wisst ihr dann freut
sich wenn man dann schon findet wenn man
zwei dann ihre länder findet das ist
eine sache die glaubt man gar nichts
heißt man unglaublich glücklich wenn man
drei ineinander findet denkt man man hat
ihnen was genommen
man ist im himmel man keine ahnung also
ihr seht schon hier was ich alles für
blut drin ist dann alleine was man hier
ausbauen kann das ist ein zombie sports
esport er genau noch skeletts borderline
was man hier ausbauten kanäle guckt euch
das mal an dann hat rice bonner
nebeneinander dass man kennt seine fette
monster von bord ohne irgendwie ohne
jegliche arten von schiiten
na ja das ganze dann wiederum auch ohne
trade off mode gegen die ganzen ob sie
unten zu schaffen ist es wieder eine
andere sache aber allein dass es so
etwas gibt und dass mir so etwas
gesendet wurde findet aber noch richtig
geil da kann dich manolis der sendeten
echt geil das sieht seine facebook seite
also wenn ihr sie hat eine facebook
seite mit sie mir wirklich fast alle an
das war wirklich alles funktioniert also
hier das ist echt hammer geil einfach
nur richtig hammer und dann will ich
sagen ich würde mich doch nicht die
freundschaft wir vielleicht 1000 likes
für die sind einfach nur aus dem geilen
sieht echt super geil und dann will ich
sagen sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal
tschüss